Dev is also friends with food shops, who claim to have POCD so
severe they had to cross the street in order to avoid spontaneous
child abuse.
>> I was just like incredibly deathly scared of kids in
general because I would be so scared that I was like a
>> Dude, how do you even argue against it? Dude, how do
you do ANYTHING AGAINST IT?
OKAY, HERE we go. Let's check this out real fast. I was told
it was funny. I want to watch it real fast. Who is this? This
is Destiny's number one sweeper. They used to do a lot of content
on me trying to attack me for covering Destiny's
uh crimes. And now they have almost entirely fallen off. And
they're reviewing a video. They're also a admitted, formerly
admitted, I believe they've recanted on that now. Now admitted
I guess.
But there's a bunch of stuff in this video of them admitting
to basically being attracted to children. Like in the video they're
about to react to, there's a bunch of stuff about them being
saying they're attracted to children. And so it would be interesting
to see how they try to sweep that as they react to it in the
first place, okay? Or as they react to this over time. This video
is about ShortFatOtaku, the guy who said Hasan
who who said the White House Correspondents Dinner shooter was
a Hasanoid.
Does he attract these chatters or does he lead them down this
dark path? Uh he attracts them. This person was obsessed with
him and banned from all of his stuff and then he needed people
who would cover him favorably at the height of his allegations
and this is one of the people who's perfectly willing to lie
about it. So, that's what they did and then he start Destiny
started going on the stream and promoting them. This is a very
close friend of Destiny's.
And yeah, the rest is history. >> Oh, it's actually by
Mrao, our favorite anti-fan local. It's 11
at lying chaser. Okay. It says fat lying chaser
and Mrao live 4 hours ago, okay? So, this person has a crush
on me and because he cannot get on me because he cannot get to
me, I think
I think he now has a vendetta against me cuz you know
he cannot get to me, right? Uh 441 views, okay? So far. 4 hours
ago, not bad. I hate Short Fat Otaku. All right, let's take a
look. Uh-oh. So, there was actually a prepared video it seems,
so good luck. >> Short Fat Otaku, despite the rancid self-deprecating
name, is a political and philosophical content creator. Going
by Dev, he struggles to gain any sense of notoriety as of recent,
failing to at least get 10,000 views to >> Uh he is struggling
career-wise, but in terms of notoriety, I'm not sure if he's
short on that. I don't I don't think he's short on notoriety.
Yeah, same thing for Epstein, actually. Epstein's struggling
a little bit career-wise, but short He's not short on notoriety.
Everybody know that. Hey, I think when it comes to notoriety,
he has plenty of that. Yeah.
Like I I think I think he has plenty of notoriety. It's just
>> Say it again. Say it again.
Does he have plenty of notoriety? >> that you know, he
his his videos have been struggling, so I understand. >> Despite
having over 140,000
sub >> Oh, yeah. Um
Oh, yeah, a little bit of a lore, okay? So, Mraw Live, the person
who made this video, is the original person who said this, okay,
about me. >> Listen, I'd be lying if there wasn't an MTF
uh that I wouldn't go crazy style >> Yep, that's him. Yep,
same person who made this video. >> Did he say that about
food shops? I'm not saying Listen, I would never say Mraw would
not make a comment about any person. Mraw, of course, is the
guy who said that he was going to break into Zip-Zip's house
to show Zip-Zip a video
of Zip-Zip a child.
And Zip-Zip took this seriously, by the way. ZipZIp thought this
was a real threat, which makes you ponder why would ZipZIp expect
there to be a video of him the child that Mau could break into
his house to show him. I don't know. And I don't know how you
could take that threat seriously. It's obviously a joke, but
I
Uh uh this is a real thing that happened, by the way. It's a
real thing that happened. >> Yep, that's talking about
me. >> Rice. These numbers are dwindling as well, but he
still keeps chugging along. Maybe if he put this much effort
into literally anything else, he wouldn't be an ugly, disgusting,
lying piece of [__] On the 26th of April, Hasan >> This
is some like reverse flash levels of hatred, dude. This is This
is some Lex Luthor Batman levels of hatred, dude. This is some
Batman against Superman levels of hatred. >> and Ben Shapiro
have a little spat on Twitter. And as you would expect from a
degenerate, bottom-feeding scum, Dev decides to try and do a
>> What the
Wait, also not only that, like why call Dev a chaser when you
yourself is a chaser? I don't I I don't I don't understand the
logic there.
Like you're you're calling him the same exact thing that you
probably are. Also, I'm pretty sure Mau is also fat. I'm pretty
sure.
I could be wrong though, but >> Why Why would that matter?
Is it like that's not Mau from describing reality?
You're fat, you can't say he's fat. Why?
I mean, if we operate by any rules, doesn't that give him a like
more of a right to call the guy fat? I thought I thought you'd
gain more of a right. Like you you have the pass. You have the
pass to call him fat, no? >> big own on Hasan, claiming
that the recent Trump shooter was actually a Hasan fan. Does
Dev show any evidence for this? No, not at all. In fact, the
shooter was actually retweeting crit >> Oh, that that is
an L on part of on part of Dev, by the way. Okay? I I do think
that is an L on a part of Dev. I I think I Yeah, the shooter
the the shooter is not a Hasan fan. It's pretty clear that the
shooter was like a um liberal, right?
>> critiques of Hasan and disagreed with him politically.
Hasan points this out and instead of taking the L, Dev says,
"Step up to debate or step off." What?
>> I I mean, at least he is willing to debate about it.
Like, I feel like whenever somebody gets held up into one of
these like positions, I feel
What? He's not. That's He's not. That's the whole point. And
you know that cuz you They Booty Jobs quote tweeted me and asked
why I had beef with Dev.
And I literally I asked, "What?"
>> feel like they just never want to debate about it, but
>> Who just lied about an attempted presidential assassin
>> I mean, I do think he's wrong. >> being a Hasan
fan, got proven wrong, and your response is "Debate me, bro."
I'm sorry, Dev. What would the debate be about, exactly? There
is zero evidence for your claim and plausible evidence for Hasan's
defense.
>> That's literally why I offered that debate. Well, actually,
the reason I offered that debate is cuz it's a perfect example
of Dev lying about somebody and then because he doesn't like
them, he doesn't feel compelled to clear it up or say he was
wrong. He just continues to lie and dodge. And I think he's a
pattern of doing that. And that's the core thesis of the video.
Did he respond? He responded once or he messaged me He like quote
tweeted me once and then I responded was like, "Hey, let's debate
this." Right? The thing he offered Hasan to debate on, let's
debate that. And he didn't respond. But I do think he's clearly
wrong. And then I was going to say, "Well, if you want to just
debate your wrong, will you do that?" And then we could have
a debate on whether or not this is a pattern for >> You
[__] idiot. But hey, just so you know I'm not compromised,
Hasan shocked his dog and as an empath, that truly affects me.
Let me introduce you to performative activism.
>> Bro, dude, I think there's too much energy, bro. What
did Dude, did Dev your
trans girlfriend or like Dude, what What's the problem? What's
the problem? Well, what did Dev do? >> He literally called
someone out to debate and then ran when somebody else offered
the same debate topic after asking what would be debated. >> What
did Dev do to you, man? >> He's annoying.
>> Did Did OH, IT'S JEALOUSY over me.
Wait. It all makes sense now. >> I don't Listen, I don't
control Mau. I don't tell him what to do. That I don't know if
that's true. I can't I can't dispute that. I can't dispute that.
I don't know. I'd have to hear from Mau >> Oh, come on,
Mau. That's a little weird, man. Now, I'm going to say that theory
does start to
that theory does start to fade as you go further in the video
and you realize that unfortunately,
he added a couple clips of food shops that are done to >> Is it
Is it Is it Oh my god, it's just because Dev is closer to me.
Oh, no. Oh my god.
It all makes sense now.
It's because he's jealous of my closeness with Dev.
But it's not because it's not because who can get closer to Dev,
it's about who can get closer to me cuz they're both chasers.
Oh my god.
OH MY GOD. Oh my god. Bro, >> Hasan is bad, so nobody's
really going to care if you lie about him. Dev gained social
capital by lying about Hasan claiming that the recent Trump shooter
was a Hasan fan. Instead of arguing in the replies for his position,
he does a quote retweet battle where he substantiates
nothing. The goal here isn't to prove that Hasan is wrong or
more specifically that Hasan does harmful content that creates
politically >> I'm pretty sure uh uh Dev is married No,
I'm I'm No, I don't think they're married yet. Um though, to
be fair, like um I think I think Dev has told me that um she
is the one.
Like she is the one. So they seem to be pretty like confident
that yeah, like she is the one.
Yeah, and it seems like they do get along, so good for them.
I want to see her maintain that energy for the next clip. Yeah.
>> I People, the goal here is to look like you're a genius
debater who owned Hasan on Twitter. You look smart to the Draconian
DGG [__] guzzlers. You've aligned yourself >> What
the
Yo, I'm telling you, dude. Reverse
Flash, okay? Professor Zoom, okay?
Not the video calling conference thing, but Professor
Zoom, okay? >> Oh, if you aren't familiar with food shops,
um calling other people anti-fans is basically the only way they
can argue back against anything, so that's typically what they
go for. It's calling other people like anti-fans and totally
dismiss arguments, never engage at all. The couple times she
did try to engage, she debated Moral, got totally destroyed,
debated Dickers, got totally obliterated, has basically avoided
any debates with anybody ever since. Like just totally dropped
the No, realizes that they don't have like the ability they they
can't do it,
>> Hey, all right. Reverse Flash only
to have this level of hatred, dude.
What in the Dude, this guy is the hater of haters. What the
Like actually insane.
Actually insane levels of hatred right here. Oh, wait. >> nothing.
Ultimately, you lied about Hasan and you will never take accountability
for this lie or these several others I will point out in this
video. Because with a dying YouTube channel and nothing really
going for you, what more can you really do while you sit on your
ass all day playing slop games. Really pushing boundaries with
the 13 live concurrent The step up in debate line Dev so
>> Is it going to be You're fat, too. That's really mean.
Or you're just hate You just hate me, or you just want my attention.
Which which not argument is going to be. She's not going to say
no, Dev's not that bad. She's not going to say anything like
that. What am I watching right now, bro?
The unhinged energy is off the charts. >> Shouts is also
extremely pathetic, given he's constantly ran from Jstock, a
streamer who is opposed to Destiny. This is important because
instead of debating Jstock, talking to him directly, or DMing
him, he would rather gossip in Destiny's chat about him. Jstock
tags him in his server to confront him for lying, and Dev doesn't
respond. Dev makes a claim about Pixie using the court system
in bad faith, says he was proven right, and yet again, Jstock
confronts him, and he doesn't respond. Dev is extremely willing
to make claims about people without substantiation. He will say
Pixie is an evil suck >> I I mean, like, to be fair, right?
Like, just to be very fair, I don't think
I don't think they deserve,
like, any amount of good faith, right? Like, normally, if this
was about like anybody
>> Where have I heard that before? Huh.
These people don't deserve any good faith. No charity to these
people at all. Where did Where did I just hear that? Hmm. >> anybody
else, if this was about anybody else, I would probably be like,
"Oh, Dev, why don't you talk to this person? This person seems
to be reasonable, and they're calling you out." But these anti-fans
are not reasonable.
These anti >> Would I say that was unreasonable? >> Anti-fans
are not reasonable, and and they're not like just calling out
for the sake of calling out. They want to get a dunk on you,
and they want it to be on >> Yeah, I do want to get a dunk
on Dev. Dev lies about me. The primary thing, by the way, these
logs right here, the reason these logs annoy me, okay, the ones
that these
is because the person, the yellow guy, that he says is like from
my community or something, that person went on a Wick panel and
said they were stalking Destiny's teenage son.
I've had a policy since the first time I broke away from Destiny's
whole [__] It like this guy's a degenerate
pervert disgusting loser. Okay, ever since I broke away I have
said I will never comment on his kid. I don't comment on his
kid. I don't watch content that involves his kid even though
his kid makes content. I don't do that. I don't do that and I
don't even comment I try not to even comment on him being a father
at all cuz I think like I I've explained that I think between
like a father and a son I think it's just improper to come between
that bond. Even if it's like even if the father's like really
imperfect but like even a bad person I just think it's I think
it's
And then this guy goes to DGG a place that is doxing people from
my Discord. Destiny's doxing people around me. Destiny's attempted
to dox me. Destiny's attempted to dox my friends. Right? He goes
to a place that community that has done all that doxing and he
starts lying about me and somebody in my community being someone
who stalks Destiny's kid.
That's totally deranged and he deserves to be called out for
it. That's why the lie is particularly egregious to me.
Because I've always gone out of my way to make sure I didn't
involve Destiny's kid in anything no matter how much I dislike
Destiny never had any blowback on his kid at That's what it's
like having principles I guess. That's that's what's hap That's
what having principles gets you. And you know what? I would still
rather have the principle >> for lying. If this was about
anybody else I would probably be like oh Deb why don't you talk
to this person? This person seems to be reasonable and they're
calling you out. But these anti-fans are not reasonable.
These anti-fans are not reasonable and
>> Reasonable implies the use of reason. I can be reasoned
with. I am reasonable.
I literally asked dude what's unreasonable? Sorry to go back
to the tweets. Nobody seems to be willing to answer me when I'm
when I ask so I'm super happy SFO's taking a look. What if the
transcript proves Pixie's using the court system in bad faith?
Do any facts from the transcript materially change the direction
of the legal case? Is that unreasonable? What's unreasonable
about that question?
What's That seems like a very reasonable
>> Normally, if this was about like anybody else, if this
was about anybody else, I would probably be like, "Oh, Dev, why
don't you talk to this person? This person seems to be reasonable
and they're calling you out." But these anti-fans are not reasonable.
These anti-fans are not reasonable and and they're not like just
calling out for the sake of calling out. They want to get a dunk
on you and they want it to be on like cam, basically.
Like they aren't there to have a good faith discussion about
whether or not like Steven is guilty or not. They They just want
to be there cuz they really hate the guy and they want to see
his career fail and, you know, whatever, right?
But yeah.
but will never explain himself. This results in Dev constantly
virtue signaling, doing performative activism, and running constantly
from debates, all while criticizing Hasan for doing the same
exact thing. What if I told you Dev actually had a pattern of
lying though, and this wasn't just the one instance with Hasan?
Let's start small. Someone asks Dev if he's okay with in this
community. Dev says, "No, that's why I banned you." In contrast,
here's a clip of Dev saying he feels bad about banning in his
community as long as they're not preying on children in his Discord.
>> If I knew for sure that someone on my server was trying
to kids and I'd ban them like 100%. Yeah, but like off your server
though?
>> Wait, what?
>> Like if none of it was happening in your spaces, I just
I don't know. >> Is he arguing that if he knew somebody
was was trying to approach kids in other spaces, he'd let them
in his space until they did it in his space? That can't possibly
be what be what he's saying, can it? I feel like that's one of
those things where I understand if somebody's like being mean,
if they're harassing someone, right? And you in a bunch of places,
you're like, "Well, if they don't do it in here, I'm not going
to ban them from here." But like grooming kids or something?
>> It feels wrong to me. On Twitter, I make a rap >> That's
extreme.
>> I don't get what's wrong with what he just said. >> Oh,
that's going to be good. Given where I know this video is going,
I've already reacted to this video today. That's going to be
good. Oh my god. I just don't get it. Yeah. If they're not If
they're not kids in your space, what's the problem, man? >> Am
I Am I the only one that like knows how to differ like between
like feels-based statements and like
affirmative prescriptions on what you should do? It sounds bad,
but then >> The feeling is bad. No, it's The feeling is
bad. >> Like it doesn't It isn't that bad.
I like
>> friends to Lilith Lovett >> I would love for them
to expand on that. Whatever that means, whatever what they just
said, whatever that means, I'd love for them to expand what they
think they mean there or expand on what they think they mean
there. Cuz I've got no idea. >> Lovett being a fan of Shadman.
Dev criticizes me for saying I came without >> Like I hope
I hope people realize that like for years
like Dev was friends with Sargon of Akkad. Like this guy is the
most
one one of the most problematic British people of all time, okay?
One of the most consequential problematic British people of all
time, okay? Like I I don't know why like this is pointing towards
Lilith Lovett Lovett when like Dev has been like best friends
with Sargon for >> This is funny considering he had no
evidence for the Hasan shooter thing, but sure. Let me substantiate
my claim unlike you. In 2018, Lilith Lovett did a cosplay of
Shadman. This was after
>> Wait, when? 2018?
Bro, you have to dig up like the dinosaur excavation brush for
this one. Like what the >> real children with Daphne Keen,
Keemstar's daughter, and Lieutenant Corbus. Lilith Lovett also
promoted the same DIY HRT website >> Oh, she's like Bro,
that was in
They're just supporting like a a guy whose drawings imagery of
someone's
Back in 2018?
OH, COME ON. THAT'S LIKE that's like 8 years ago, man. What's
a little in the past, dog?
Also, I love that she basically considered being friends with
Sargon the same as being friends with uh or having lax rules
with regards to
Very, I mean, kind of true, but also a little [__]
up, no? I mean, I do judge people who are friends or fans of
Sargon, but that's just a little much, no?
Who cares?
2018? Like how long is that ago? 8 years
Bro, I bet that dude when when 8 years ago, Mau was probably
in his baby's crib. Like
What the >> is Keffals? The same one with these packaging.
The same one that was criticized for attempting to circumvent
parents in order to give children hormone replacement therapy.
Dev is also friends with Food Shops who claim to have POCD so
severe they had to cross the street in order to avoid spontaneous
child abuse. >> Like for example
>> Let's go. >> Oh my god, not this [__]
again, bro. Oh my god, every time, every time, bro.
>> Well, I wouldn't even walk on the same side of the street
as a kid, like in real life, just because I had POCD. I was deathly
scared of kids. Yeah, I was just like incredibly deathly scared
of kids in general because I would be so scared that I was like
a real
>> I like I like how like he's playing this as if
Dude, how do you even argue against it? Dude, how do you do ANYTHING
AGAINST IT?
DUDE, IT'S so rough, man. Oh my god.
>> Like Mau hasn't himself said that he would hit on a
17-year-old.
And he
>> You think that's the same?
oh my god.
When you said child, did you mean a 17-year-old? I know you didn't.
It's so funny. Oh, this guy hit on a 17-year-old when he was
20 or 21. THIS GUY IS SICK. NOT like me who had to cross the
street so I wouldn't kids. Not like Not like me. >> He
and he would like knowingly hit on a 17-year-old. Okay, so really
nice projection there. That I would convince
>> It's so weak. It's just so weak, man.
That's crazy, man. When he was 20? I think he was 20 or Yeah,
20. 17 to 20, it's like dude, that's not even a crazy age gap,
man.
>> that was a monster that even being like even breathing
like the same air as children would be like violate like be a
>> Food shops attempt to show email >> Like I I don't
I don't like like I don't quite understand
what exactly is the point of like showing this? Just mainly because
like I think this was during a time I think this was during a
time which like I was like really really open with the internet
about like my various mental disorders, especially OCD, right?
And even if it sounds like bad at first, the only reason I'm
saying these out in the open in the first place is because like
I was cognizant, right? I was cognizant of Oh yeah, I have this
issue. I'm going to go treat it, right? >> This is sort
of the defense Lunar Box tried to do a food shops, but it's not
really a good defense for most people. You could maybe have that
be a defense with Lunar Box as like the most progressive guy
in terms of like in all of this [__] that exists
on Earth.
With 99.999%
of people, that's ain't going to fly, dog.
That [__] 9% of people are like wood chipper, wood
chipper, or chipper. The The next point niner are like, "Ugh,
gross, man. Don't be around me." There's like a very, very tiny
percentage of people who will actually support someone who's
made these admissions online. Thank god for food
Like, 80% of them are DG gears, so she picked her market well.
>> But, like, these people don't believe in any kind of
mental help or therapy or anything. So, it's like, yeah, I wouldn't
expect them to understand it, >> to justify their therapist
supposedly prescribing lolicon pornography. >> Like, like,
what like what do Like, seriously, what do What was I supposed
to say? Like, "Oh, yeah, I should like on purpose be closer to
kids." Like, is that Is that something that like the anti-fans
want me to do back then? It is just like be closer to kids?
Is that the Is that the other >> No, I I already said the
prescription 2 seconds ago. It's what 99% of people would tell
you. That's the prescription.
I'm sorry. That's That is like the prescription most people consider
appropriate here. That's just what it is, man. I don't know what
to I don't know what to tell you, man.
as an answer to this troubling problem, the image >> There
is Hold on. There is also something to be said for They're pretending
that talking about this publicly was a good thing. When you talk
about it publicly, it shows me that you don't have self-control,
you don't have judgment, right? If you don't have self-control,
you don't have judgment in like a If you're just doing this for
like five viewers,
you are a dangerous person to me. I think you're a dangerous
person at that point. You are a danger to kids. I'm sorry. You
You can't control yourself, and I think you're participating
in some kind of fetish thing by telling people this. You're a
weirdo. I don't I don't trust you at all. >> mail had nothing
about or POCD included. Later, food shops admitted that it was
only briefly
>> So, you've been to therapy for the POCD thing, and you
can see them separately. So, have you Have you ever told your
>> I I went to >> I went to therapy for OCD in general,
for sure, yeah. >> So, have you ever Have you Does does
the the something like that come up in your therapy sessions?
You don't have to tell >> This is deep lore. This is deep
lore, okay? Like unironically.
>> Uh it came up in one session only and only as a side
tangent.
>> Food Shop slide about being prescribed
to attempt to justify consumption and even views >> No,
I don't think I've lied at any point over the course of that
drama. >> No, you No, you very No, you very very probably
lied. You very probably lied. You You totally claimed it was
a doctor who said you should do this. A doctor told you to do
this. And then you basically revealed that No, no, no, it was
like a side tangent and one thing we talked about. And you have
admitted, I believe overtly, that it was self-prescribed at this
point. I think you've overtly admitted it. >> And and like
it's it's almost like physically impossible for me to knowingly
lie. Just mainly because
>> It's almost physically impossible. You're doing it now.
There's no way she's like, I don't think I've ever lied about
this and it's almost physically impossible for me to knowingly
lie. I mean, do you hit yourself in the head with a hammer?
Is that your excuse? You like consistently
brain damage yourself to forget things and so you don't knowingly
That's the only thing I can think of >> Cuz like Um I think
also part of OCD is like this um fear of like guilt, right? And
I think that if I ever knowingly lied, like I would feel really,
really guilty about it. So, it's like like it's almost physically
impossible for me to knowingly lie. Like it that's not that's
not possible,
What is What is this video? I don't know. Like I would like to
say like it's a dev video, but like apparently it's automatically
transitioned to being like a Food Shop's anti-fan video, which
is like fantastic, okay? >> When people bring up facts
I don't like, they're anti-fans, actually. They're just deranged
haters. They're just deranged anti-fans.
Stop bringing up the clips. Stop bringing up these clips. >> You know
what? Stuff from 3 to 4 years ago, hell yeah, bring it all up
again, okay? Just so you know, okay? Like this brown guy probably
still has a crush on me. So, I I don't know why from his perspective
he's into someone who says all of these things, all right? >> Like
do we just notice that she's
There There is no attempt to explain the footage that's already
been played, right? She says, "Well, I I didn't I didn't say
that." I believe it got played. You saying that you got prescribed
this This was something you talked to your therapist about. Then
the email is shown where you don't actually get any notes from
your therapist that your therapist doesn't mention POCD, and
then you basically admit later on that you only ever talked once
about POCD in any way as a side tangent of a session.
Which doesn't mean anything. >> All right, it's all very
suspicious to me. Like does he want to be the in this scenario
in like a role-play scenario? Kind of weird, if you ask me, okay?
But >> as drawn child >> Yes, I consume Okay. Yes,
I recognize it is drawn chop
I disagree with this. Um I think that >> What? Your honor,
permission to treat the witness as hostile. Your honor, this
person is not credible. Your honor, this person is not credible.
We cannot enter this testimony into the record.
>> I recognize it is drawn chop
I disagree with this. Um I think that
Like at the end of the day, like it implies that there's an actual
child victim, but yeah. Okay.
>> Okay, but is there a victim in the Okay, maybe there's
a victim in the drawing cuz of the shadman thing. Maybe, but
I would I would say drawn is just drawn kids in a fact is is
what that's >> with that. >> I will say FoodShops
isn't But really, let's just hear it from FoodShops themselves.
>> you're a girl and you're trying to hold yourself off
with
right? You're trying to like hold yourself off so you don't >> I
am a I like femininity.
>> Yeah, that's a joke. That's what jokes >> like
a more or less.
>> I do actually think that one example of them calling
themselves a is a joke, but unfortunately it's followed up by
many other Well, sorry, it's preceded by an example of her just
talking about being attracted to kids, which is not confusing
or really a joke in any way. It's also another weird >> and
like masculinity
>> I want a cute little girl that I can wrap my arms around.
I need to I need to have a little girl to wrap myself around.
I need to have like a >> It's hard to keep >> Yeah,
that's a shock jock humor, okay?
Um this is 3 to 4 years ago. >> Very, very consistent through
line on this shock jock humor.
Am I wrong? Where's the rest of the shock jock humor that accompanied
this? Was there a lot of other shock jock humor in different
directions or was it all pretty much going in one direction that
also your totally serious compassionate conversations lined up
with? Strange. >> Well, like like back when I was a um
earlier content creator, like I was like
way crazy. I was super crazy. It's all just very embarrassing
now, but yeah. I mean there's there's nothing else I can do,
okay? Like like these are just like really embarrassing clips,
yeah, but
yeah. Like nowadays I definitely watch what I'm saying, but yeah.
>> Devon is word.
>> I believe she leaned into the thing like a month ago.
Like when she was fighting with Dan maybe two, three months ago,
she leaned into the thing again. She's learned nothing. She's
like it, dude. Come on, man. >> Remember this guy has me
saved? Yes.
You should reread their manifesto. [__] no, okay?
Good try, okay? Peaceful clipper. All right. Good try, okay?
>> When he's so obviously
compromised at the sight of a borderline cross-dresser, really
taking in the pre-transition photos as he went along. His wife
even caught onto this, making fun of him for chasing mid trans
on >> Oh man, so
I got a private message of Scra >> Oh, now we're back to
Dev, okay.
he was talking to other people it was like leaked to me from
a few months ago. >> He was He's now saying that apparently
I was like in love with Lilith and I was pining over her while
he was near the whole time. Like
>> I I think as far as I'm concerned, like
Lilith love it and like SFO, they're just friends. Like I don't
I don't think I've
ever seen a clip of them having any kind of romantic tension
between them. >> Well, SFO's partner disagrees, thankfully.
Thankfully, SFO's partner is going to disagree on this one. Dev
is married? I don't know if it's his wife or not. I think he
might say wife, but I don't know if they're legally >> Like
it's it's a really weird thing to kind of like put out there
that like a man and a woman can't be friends with one another
because
well, like if if if a man and a woman are friends, like one of
them has to have feelings for the other. I
>> I don't think that's the argument. I think the argument
is Dev has a like borderline uncontrolled
uncontrollable fetish for trans women and that he probably can't
have like he probably can't have platonic relationships with
trans women. That he is a chaser, he is a fetish and he can't
control it and so he is not seeking out platonic relationships
when he talks to trans women online. >> I think it's just
ultimately a very toxic mindset to have, but you know, I
Like I I don't know. The Like these concepts are like foreign
to people like now who just like stay online all day and then
like they can't they literally cannot conceive of any kind of
like
normal friendship between a man and a woman. It's just silly,
but
>> Also, just so you know, Lilith is Lilith love it is
trans and I would not be surprised if Ram also want to [__]
her, okay? Like out of spite.
She's cute, but no, I was never interested because I'm not like
a
>> That's not true. You flirted.
>> Not really.
>> I feel like I feel like ultimately, like maybe this
is just something I disagree with, but like I don't
>> Not going to engage with the wife disagreeing? No? Not
at all? >> See anything wrong with people flirting with
friends all that. >> I I don't think I've ever seen anything
that's not just platonic and friendly between Lilith Lovett and
Dev.
Look how fluidly she swapped to I don't see anything wrong with
these friends like flirting a little bit. >> I think that
I think that there are limits to draw, like I don't think you
should cross the boundary into cheating. But like I don't know,
man. Like maybe this is just like
me being gay and then like having like female friends or whatever
the heck, but like all the female friends would just like flirt
openly with
female friends. I don't know, like
Like even if even if like they were already like
they had another partner or something. It's just Yeah.
I mean maybe Like like here's the thing, I can't speak for Dev's
relationship. I can't, okay? But I can I can only say things
that I myself have seen, right?
I myself have seen I don't think I've seen much of like Lilith
and Dev, okay?
>> Try to do this without getting
It was it was ridiculous.
>> Like the only time I think I've ever had Dev approach
me about Lilith is when like when it was like more of a personal
emergency and it had nothing to do with romance. Yeah. >> Gee,
I wonder what Oh, come on, man. Come on, man. Don't do it to
me.
Oh, I don't WANT TO SAY IT. STATISTICALLY WE KNOW THAT WOULD
BE
>> TIMING? Definitely not. And one wanted a good down from?
Yes.
>> Dev's wife revealing that Dev's a bottom for these trans
women is pretty crazy.
That's nuts, bro. >> have any honest, real conversation
with you anymore because you're like this right now.
>> Listen, listen, I'm on your side. I'm still saying
>> Did HE SAY NO, YOU'RE NOT? >> I'M STILL saying
>> She says, "I'm on your side." and he says, "No, you're
not." I didn't catch that the first time. >> I'm asking
if you can >> Okay.
Not like actual flirting, just like casual, just being like like
[__] Twitter flirt. You say you traps on Twitter
all the time. >> It's not flirting, it's goofing around.
Flirting means Okay, for it to be an actual flirt and not just
a joke, there has to be real intent behind it.
>> Okay. Foot Chops has to totally disagree with that one,
right? Now?
Right, Foot Chops? Radar's got to be up. You got to totally disagree
with that. You just said flirting could be totally platonic and
>> Chat, I need a poll. >> You got to talk about
that? >> I need a poll about what I'm >> this year,
Astro. >> I I I feel like flirting like implies that there
is like you want to go somewhere with it. >> Dude, they
were This person was just arguing that they flirt with all of
their female friends and it's not going to go anywhere. They
just argued this 30 seconds ago. Do they not have like object
permanence? Can they not remember what they just argued 30 seconds
ago? >> There's intent behind it, right? But like there
is such thing as like What do you call platonic flirting? There's
no such thing as platonic flirting, right? I'm so confused. >> No,
really.
We're talking to other people and it was >> I want >> Hold
on, hold on, hold on. >> I was super crazy. It's all such
Remember that another people that was like already into cheating.
But like I don't know, man. Like maybe this is just like
me being gay and then like having like female friends or whatever
the heck. But like all the female friends would just like flirt
openly with
female friends. I don't know. Like
Like even if even if like they were already like
they had another partner or something. It's just Yeah.
I mean maybe Like like here's the thing. I can't speak for that.
>> So, you wouldn't go into cheating, but flirting means
intent and you do it with people who have partners, I guess.
>> They're like flirting like implies that there is like
you want to go somewhere with it.
Right? Like there there is intent behind it, right? But like
there there is such thing as like What do you call platonic flirting?
There is no such thing as platonic flirting, right? I'm so confused.
But also like I'm not here to comment on like any kind of relationship
problems that Dev may have because he has a long history. He
has he has a long history of like him um having his history online,
right?
Um like for other people to dig into, right? Like I can like
here's the thing that's kind of unfair, right? Um Dev's own relationship
problems are his own relationship problems, okay? Ultimately
at the end of the day, okay? But like this snarking means very
little to me, right? Because I would imagine that if any anti-fan
if any anti-fan would
go on to like also stream their life like this
If any anti-fan were to also stream their life like this, I don't
think it would be even close
to as like good as this, I mean, right? Like much less like being
in the same room as a woman, right?
That is
>> All right. It's not their mom or their sister, okay?
>> This is This is why we had to recruit Sleepy to the
anti-fan cause, okay? So to speak.
They can't make this argument no more. We got Sleepy on our side,
okay? We got a looks maxer on our side now. You guys
>> But like Yeah, I don't know. Um I just none of my business.
Like any kind of relationship issue, that's not my business unless
like I'm being asked about it. Unless like like I'm actually
being like because you know, Def is a close associate of mine.
So like I'm not >> Like like like like like like >> to
like
get in between him and, you know, his partner of like 10 years,
by the way,
But yeah. >> About whether or not telling a woman you'd
[__] her on Twitter counts as
>> Intent is a part of flirting, you dummy.
>> I'm not cheating. I'm just goofing
>> It's not cheating, though. >> Hey, I I recognize
that thumbnail style. Hey, I recognize that thumbnail style.
Hey, hey, hey!
>> Def framing his relationship with Lilith as a normal
is a bit dishonest. He was really interested in this trans body.
>> The fact that they are still together
I don't know, should indicate to you that they probably go and
solve their issues, right? Unless like maybe they are completely
immature and whatever at the age of like 30-something.
Like I just doubt I just doubt like there is actually any like
real issue here. If it doesn't work out for them in the end,
then I don't see how that's like the issue of any of the anti-fans.
I I just I just don't get like if whether or not the relationship
works out is none of the anti-fans business, but they're going
to make it their business because, you know, they're going to
be snarking on the relationship, right? They're
>> This isn't snarking on the relationship at all.
I mean, other than the fact that she's like mad, this isn't snarking
on his relationship. This is laughing at him lying about being
attracted or flirting with this trans woman, chasing this trans
woman. Which he's basically lied about it twice >> They're
going to be snarking on the circumstances
of um you know, Def's relationship with her. Which is like I
think just, you know, obviously it's a douchebag thing to do,
right? Um like your your relationship failures and
um like being judged by people on the internet, especially when
Dev is being open about his relationship by gaming
with his girlfriend is just
I don't know, it's just it's just disgusting, okay, in my opinion,
but
>> I'm not cheating. I'm just goofing
>> It's not cheating, though. >> Dev framing his
relationship with Lilith as a normal is a bit dishonest. He was
really interested in this trans body, so much so that he would
go on to her Kiwi Farms thread and start defending her from A-logs.
Not well, mind you, a lot >> Wouldn't you defend a friend?
>> Like Kiwi Farms is supposed to defend a friend? No.
Literally interacting with Kiwi Farms is always a mistake.
Like literally any reference to yourself or your friends on Kiwi
Farms, interacting with that is always a mistake, massive mistake.
You never interact with that stuff in public, that's totally
insane. This person just said something completely insane. Wouldn't
you go defend a friend? No. No, obviously not. Are you out of
your mind? >> Wouldn't you defend a friend? >> Like
this is another like weird thing that like
literally nobody in the real world would be able to relate to,
by the way. Like nobody in the real world would be like oh, well
>> No, everybody would defend one of their boys if they're
getting made fun of in real life or yeah, obviously, or in some
like real life social scenario. Something at university, something
at your job. Everybody defend a friend there. Everybody understands
that. We're all saying, "No, this is weird. This is different.
This is a different thing. You're going in This is a different
thing, obviously."
Different in kind. >> See, they're in love with one another.
Like I like I need more evidence than this. By the way, these
like anti-fans, they pride themselves on evidence. They pride
themselves on like whatever the right, but like clearly there
are holes, right? Like
>> Wasn't the accusation just that Dev hangs out with and
chases
And he's basically shown two people who have very questionable
at best. Well, sorry, Lilith Lovett has some questionable past,
right? Actually, I think it was defenders or something for Lilith.
But in any case,
like Food Chops objectively called themselves a multiple times,
but Lilith Lovett has the shad that thing and the what the the
whole youth gender medicine stuff that that hormones, the bathtub
hormones. Right? That's pretty questionable, man. I question
I question who you are if you support that.
>> But like where is the evidence that like since you made
a claim here that Dev was into Lilith, right? Where where is
the like where's the evidence? I'll
>> His girlfriend mocking him for denying
Girlfriend mocking him for denying it
And him getting upset about it. >> Side of like um
Dev and his um girlfriend >> Oh, and that other guy that
other guy who is saying it and Dev was bringing up somebody else
saying it who was with that girl.
Is it part Oh god, what is this? Oh god, what is this?
Oh god, what is this? What did you just link me? Miracle
Miracle What did you just link me? What is this? Marvin, what
is this?
>> having like a brief spat over it, right? in public.
Like where exactly is the evidence cuz I don't see it.
Like yeah, there's a clear lack of like shown proof of any of
these claims. >> the messages are just gross comments,
uh but an attempt was made nonetheless. Dev also lied in my little
Twitter spat with him doing yet another quote retweet, which
I'm sure makes him >> Bro, this is like number one hater
type bro. Like the hatred
the hatred, okay? >> All it took for was people on him
for befriending befriending several
I feel like I feel like Mau has gone out of his way to substantiate
this.
I think so. I love the video "I hate SFO". It is the That is
the title of the video. That's
Was she shocked Is she shocked by the content of the video? The
video is called "I hate short fat otaku".
Doesn't seem very confusing.
What What is this?
Dev says this person, "I don't care. F'sler, go pearl clutch
uh somewhere else. I don't reveal the secrets of friends, but
Amy is not a friend. And if she's going to talk repeatedly, I'm
going to set the record straight." And this person comes in and
says, "I talked to you once because your brain has melted past
the point of no return from harassing VTubers with your mods
to switching political sides every damn minute as if you have
no solid ground to step on. You're involved in nearly a trillion
dramas where you are a bad guy or the biggest in the room. I
hate that despite all that, in the comments, you keep you calling
me a political radical. It's type of person you cut off as if
it wasn't me who slowly stepped who stopped keeping up with you
because of the you keep doing. Saying we were never at least
friends is crazy considering you still have me added and the
before our last message was an indicator of some closeness case.
Occasion point, since you want to start DM the DM leaking train,
except I'm not I'm not ashamed of what I say.
Except I'm not ashamed of what I say, okay? You're even comfortable
enough that your girlfriend would save my nudes and you would
make jokes about me cuz I kept not appearing on your podcast.
I don't know what you got under your under you that you think
you could just lie as if you barely knew me or talked to me,
but you should sort that the [__] out. I really really
stopped trying to interact with you after the other million dramas
you got involved with, especially after the one with Kirsh.
Friendship eroded cuz you are the political radical, not me.
Amy, "Ah, you're moving from Twitter. Sorry for whatever I did."
Dude, you kept tagging me in both on both private and public
a lot of that is considered racist and people can search my public
ads. When you stop doing that I can follow you back if you wish.
I don't think I tagged the Amy with it. Sorry if I did, sorry
that was an accident. You're gay why this time? You're gay feels
good man. Still going to [__] your girlfriend let's
do it together. Wait Amy I thought you were into this. Ironically
showed my girlfriend your stream and she thought your voice was
great. Yes gay a y y ree on Twitter. My 39 Amy got porch spidered
can't talk about it publicly because police are involved.
Oh damn you nuked all the curious cat. Were they really going
for you lol? So once Lilith and I get everything up and running
for our new shop you can still be on it if you like in exchange
for one nude. Smile. No rip my 100k sub attempt has failed. Now
you'll cancel me 3 years later.
September 2021 post November 5th 2024. That is about 3 years
later. Let's go.
Let's [__] go. Awesome. Very cool.
People respond to this?
I don't know how this didn't think at least once. Hey she keeps
brushing me off while I contact her maybe she's really fed up
with how I behave. No it's she was a radical and a person to
be so it was me who's trying to disassociate from her. You were
the problem and still are and if you want to talk about it I'm
glad to but you are as untrustworthy as a broken branch on the
side of a cliff.
Loser.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah it's basically as about what it is. As about
what it is man. That's about what it is. What a guy. Back to
this reaction right here.
The hatred is crazy.
Feels super badass saying how he doesn't pay attention to my
part of the internet implying he never saw Jstalk's offer to
debate. This is such an obvious lie I don't know why he even
typed this out. I have personally seen ShortSquid Otaku in Queenman's
chat. He has called into Turkey Tom's streams. He made a video
about Otaku in Queenman's >> However, I will admit here
that I'm attracted to other trans women, just not this one. LOL.
Uh-huh. That's the chat on Queenman's stream. Okay. All right.
>> Queenman's chat. He has called into Turkey Tom's streams.
He made a video about ShortSquid
>> That raw video was rough for an audience that usually
doesn't watch drama stuff. I bet it was. Yeah, raw was a bit
of a
a cold shock of water. I don't even know how to say it. >> Conroy.
He calls into Wick streams frequently. You engage with Destiny.
You go into his offline chat and Jstock when you're too scared
to say it to his face. So much for those safe spaces you constantly
complain about. >> Well, why why why should
I got I guess my question is like why shouldn't you lie to anti-fans?
>> I just declaring you an anti-fan. I declare you an anti-fan
so I can do whatever I want. I don't have to have any principles.
>> Uh-huh. Reminder, she said she could not
>> Right, she's physically incapable of lying. Well, what's
wrong with lying about these people? >> I think I think
at some point during my coverage I think I think I've literally
said that these people do not deserve your good faith. Right?
I >> Yeah, you don't good faith doesn't mean
Unless you think it's being a good person to not lie, it's literally
just like a neutral act. Not lying is a neutral act.
Saying something kind or doing something kind, that's good.
But what what the hell? Just be truthful. Well, unless there's
Maybe there's some philosophical implication there I don't know
about. If you say like being truthful is not necessarily a good
act, it's just like the neutral.
There might be some deeper philosophy there I'm not picking up
at all. I don't think of I just tell the truth as
Most people do. I think essentially everybody does.
>> I feel like I feel like SFO is just putting to use the
lessons that I have taught like during my coverages about the
anti-fans, essentially speaking.
Like I feel like I've taught like a lot of these lessons about
like, oh yeah, I do think it's justified to lie to these people
because they're wretched. They're They're like wretched stalkers,
right? So, like I don't know. Like I I feel like that's just
kind >> This person did like a million videos on me and
I did like two on them.
Not that like listen, you want to go stalk people's content of
the internet, you want to respond to their online content, which
by the way, they don't. They like essentially don't respond to
the things I say ever.
They never have. They basically just stole my content and reposted
it on YouTube cuz they're a worthless loser.
if they were like just engaging with the content, I I've no problem
with that.
You know? You know? You know?
>> kind of adhering to it.
Adhering to that, no? >> Now, by the way, in January, Dev
tweets out saying, "I actively killed my own channel rather than
sell out to MAGA. I have zero regrets."
This frames Dev as being a principled individual, one unwilling
to sacrifice his values for things like money >> I forgot
that actually food shops herself here. This is This is over.
Now, he's going to make the point that your principles are important,
especially against like literally maybe primarily for the people
you hate.
That's how you decide whether or not somebody's principled.
Very easy to say I'm going to be truthful and honest and friendly
to people who are nice to me. It's really hard to say I'm going
to be truthful and honest about somebody who doesn't like me.
Right? That's the actual difficult thing, to not lie, to not
just make things up about somebody you dislike. That's what's
actually >> or social influence. Dev lied about
>> If you duck view you don't get to call other people.
Are you talking about Dev?
Because Dev has debated the anti-fans before. I'm pretty sure
I covered it >> And when >> No, they're saying that
I should debate Destiny and I'm I literally will debate anybody
else. I don't care. I don't care who I talk to. I'm just not
debating
Literally not worth it ever ever. >> He was proven wrong.
He refused to engage. Dev ran from debating J Stokes and lied
saying he doesn't pay attention to the space >> Wait. Wait.
Is it Is it J Stokes declining to speak to Steven?
Or is it Steven declining to speak with J Stokes? Because one
of them is definitely avoiding the other, right?
>> Um I mean at some point Destiny was not wanting to speak
to me and then it
But I I'm just not talking to him I've watched him too many times
just totally like over peace go to bunch of other people. Like
just I've no interest, man. >> I'm pretty sure Wait, right?
I'm I I don't I don't see any reason for Steven to turn down
like an encounter with J
yeah, who knows? >> Is he himself is in as justification.
Dev has a history of saying doxing is bad. They stalk. They dox
and they're not above IRL harassment including four >> Be
because because most of the time doxing is not justified, right?
Like if if I were to say colloquially killing people is wrong,
that doesn't mean that I'm not like and in the next breath >> This
is so worthless a conversation because then you have to actually
prove out why they've done something that deserves whatever you're
doing in
and nobody's ever taken that step. Destiny's literally never
done that. He's basically showed some logs that have nothing
to do with the original thing he doxed for and gone, "Look, I
was right." And then because he does the tone indicators, people
go, "Oh my god. Oh my god, thank you for proving it, Destiny.
Thank you." But none of them have the sentience required to actually
explain why that actually works, which is why I'm totally fine
with debating any of those people.
Right? Absent tone indicators, absent the cult leader, the cult
falls apart completely. It's very funny. >> I say that
oh killing in self-defense is
That's not like like obviously what I mean by killing is like
murdering, right? Like if I say killing is bad, right? Obviously
I'm talking colloquially speaking in most cases killing is bad,
right?
Dude, like this is a level of autism that like it is >> The
funny thing about this is this actually good explanation, right?
But self-defense is an affirmative defense as in you don't get
you have to prove it. You don't it's not oh well, I get to kill
somebody and then I'm like prove that I prove that I was not
acting in self-defense. No, you need to prove that you were acting
in self-defense.
Right? And DGGers have lost that entirely. I've asked them for
that a thousand times. Destiny's never written anything up on
it and all of his cult has just said, "Yeah, no Destiny can dox
that guy and that guy and that guy and that guy." And essentially
it's just for being mean in content.
is obviously like such bad faith autism, like just completely
unserious people. >> Not sure if food shops would know
what an affirmative defense is, so
Um I'm mostly just arguing with myself. >> People like
completely
>> and prank [__]
Hey, let's not mock people who left a six-figure job to stream,
okay? What the >> Like ordering a bunch of pizzas and taxi
cabs to someone's house. >> Yet he participates in communities
where doxxing is not only done but justified and celebrated.
Short Fato Taku is a coward, a liar, an unprincipled loser grasping
desperately for any sense of relevancy by epically co >> I
think that Ralph like very very much justified the hatred. He
justified exactly why he doesn't like this guy.
I I've not heard an argument back on any of this stuff. I've
just heard cope. It's just been cope the entire time. Not a tangible
argument back on anything Ralph saying.
>> Quote tweeting Hassan despite very clearly being in
the wrong. But hey, Hassan is bad, so it's all justified, I guess.
The entire point of principle >> Yeah, but but it's not
like oh, yeah, Hassan is bad, okay? It's funny that the anti-fans
say this, but like these days, do you know what they're doing?
They're defending Hassan. Like they are actively It's not just
that Hassan is bad. Do you know what it is? THESE DAYS THEY'RE
ACTIVELY DEFENDING HASSAN. Could you
>> They're actually defending him. Yeah, this is a lie.
You're a lying piece of [__]
I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I don't need any more. I'm done.
I don't need to participate in the lies. Okay? Okay?
Is this from Hutch? Is it the Hutch Ryan Grim thing? Hutch is
a [__] I It's very depressing to watch. >> Hassan,
okay? It isn't that Hassan is bad or or that being like a caveat
or whatever, is that they are actively like praising Hassan.
Seven months >> Hassan is cool and he's, as far as we can
tell, not a predator, not a degenerate, not a like uh pervert.
He's none of these disgusting things that everybody
Dev and Destiny and you are. And so, you know what? I [__]
with Hassan. I'll [__] with the guy who's got the
end Laura. Seems to be working out pretty well. That's all I'm
saying.
I'm not calling anybody anything, but I'm going to hang out with
the guy who's got the Laura and things you guys seem to just
sort of be nuking yourselves over and over again. >> I
just want to say like, yeah, Dev is wrong here, okay? Like he
is. He's not correct, okay? But like
anti-fans suck. Hassan now.
They suck Hassan now.
Right? Like shamelessly, I'm saying, crazy style. What might
he >> Doing what? Be like this Listen.
>> You can say >> I would love to hear your justification.
>> sloppy toppy style, okay? Like we're like we're not
just talking about like begrudgingly saying, oh, yeah, Hassan
>> Examples examples examples >> Yes, like I'm talking
about like they're actively worshipping this okay? Like Jstark
literally set up his twitch times so then he could possibly get
rated by Hassan. So in case one day
>> What? I've streamed at the same time pretty consistently
for like two years
Ah, I just got unbanned on twitch.
>> He ever gets rated by Hassan um like his twitch times
lining up. So then he starts after Hassan. Like >> I've
just always streamed at this time.
>> I have seen it before. I have seen him say that before.
It is it >> By the way, I I picked this time because it
was like slightly it was like before when I was first starting
it was like before Destiny ended. Right? That was the time I
picked. That was where I started streaming. So like she's almost
right but then I just kept streaming at this time cuz it's where
I built an >> Embarrassing.
Okay? Like this is not just begrudgingly saying >> Think
he mentioned a Hassan raid once? I've I've just joked about it
Guys, today we're going to get the Hassan raid. Hassan won't
raid my
I don't know if any of you guys think that's going to happen.
Hassan will not raid my channel. There's a reason he will retweet
substance but not me, right? He did make criticisms of me. He
doesn't want to get called a hypocrite and I think like probably
you know stuff like saying the soft A, he don't like that stuff.
Which is fine.
Totally fine, man. >> That Hassan is bad. This is like
actively sucking him, okay? But >> is that they work for
people you don't like or even >> R word? Okay, if Grand
Platypus can say the R word then I can too. And plus I don't
even use the R word all that much. It was mostly just uh we we
covered some Destiny politics content today. It was >> Then
your enemies. Dev is compromised and will lie about people he
doesn't like to defame them and will lie about people he does
like to try to make them seem less bad than they actually >> He
hasn't lied at all. Okay. Any any kind of inconsistency was probably
because like due to 3 to 4 years ago, like I was actively crashing
out. So then like obviously I'm not going to be perfect in terms
of speaking, right? Now I am. Okay. Now I'm confident in the
way that I talk about things. Okay.
>> Yeah, but we have all the lies on the
You like you you were
you were explicitly trying to get out of
and lying to get out of trouble.
So you might have like a script for how to talk about it now,
but the lies are all on the record. Why you lied, how you lied,
it's all on the record. It's like not something you can walk
back now. It's like Richard Nixon a way way later, like 30 years
later being like, "Guys, I can totally explain Watergate."
Who cares? We don't want your answer.
Hello, who is this? >> you What do you think of Food Shop
>> I thought it was very funny.
I'm trying to think of like some of the funny stuff. The funny
One funny thing to me was when she was like, "I flirt with my
female friends all the time." And then she basically goes, "It
doesn't mean anything." And then like literally 4 minutes later
she goes, "I I don't even think you could flirt platonically.
I don't think that
Uh yeah, she's she's predating all those women she claims to
be platonic friends with 100%.
>> Yeah, it's uh I just can't believe that
Dev embarrassed himself like this. Well, I can't believe it,
but I don't know why you would stick your neck out in such a
way when all the shit's out there. >> Oh, Dev or
Food Shop's or both? >> Dev. Dev.
>> I mean >> Food Shop's is just like beyond fried.
Like there's not even any point talking about. Oh, Food Shop
Food Shop's you're already embarrassing yourself online. Okay,
yeah. You know what I mean? >> She really can't be It's
like she she peaked within the first year, so it's like you >> It's
like over the first year first 6 months, dude. >> It's
what happens when you watch Mr. Girl in her unmedicated, okay?
It's not healthy for people.
She couldn't handle it.
Try to copy it. Really it up. Not good,
What what were the other funny moments? When she's like trying
to say how she didn't lie. Ralo like perfectly lays the lie out
and she's like, "I didn't lie about this."
You go back and watch it explain. You try to explain to me. He
like lays out how you can you said this that you were >> I
I I'm magically incapable of lying. Literally magically incapable
of lying. It's awesome.
>> It's pig. >> She said she's incapable of lying.
>> Yeah, is Kenny saying this yet? Kenny Kenny would love
this. Kenny would be like clapping and cheering, punching the
air if he had food shops claim that she's magically incapable
of lying. So she couldn't possibly lie about a PhD.
Literally, dude. He'd love it. >> Did you watch like somewhere
near the end where she basically says also she's like, "But also,
what's even wrong with lying about these anti-fans?" >> Yeah,
yeah, yeah. You're allowed to lie. Yeah. I'm magically incapable
of lying, but also actually lying is justified and you're allowed
to do that.